hey guys what's up you guys were
freaking out messaging me about this
video so I'm going to explain what's
going on it's vision versus the coal
obsidian or the version they're going to
use in the movies so what this is is
somebody snagged a bunch of behind the
scenes of vision filming a
special-effects sequence so you don't
see the other person they're going to be
adding them as CG getting his ass handed
to him so I changed the audio track on
this because it was pretty lame but here
we go
[Music]
the cool thing about this is that there
are very few things in the universe to
get hand vision his ass and Thanos
forces are really high on that list so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I do Marvel
and DC every week there's going to be
crazy behind-the-scenes infinity war
stuff happening this summer
so this basically confirms Corvus glaive
from the black order is going to be
coming for vision probably to get the
mind gem so in the version of infinity
Avengers infinity if you haven't seen it
was a couple years ago in the Marvel
Universe it's not the same thing as the
Infinity Gauntlet it's sort of a
retelling of Thanos trying to track down
all of his children kill them and then
the Avengers trying to prevent the other
incursions from killing their own
version of Earth so it's like the
multiverse collapsing on itself because
the beyonders are like okay we're done
with this experiment so Doctor Strange
Doctor Doom in the rest of the Avengers
from all the different multiverses are
trying to stop all of their earths from
being destroyed so his fantasies black
order was coming for the different gems
that were possessed by different members
of the Illuminati so I'll explain who
had which gems in a second because it
was a little different from the movie
version that they're going to be going
with but everything else in the universe
was collapsing around them so it was so
crazy so obviously I don't think it's
going to be this nuts in the movies they
tend to simplify things but in the
movies vision has the mind gem in the
comics it was Doctor Strange so each
member of the black order is looking for
the gems or looking for Thanos his son
so Corvus glaive who it looks like
they're doing motion capture for here
I'll explain his blade in a second
because it gives him all kinds of
special powers he's actually looking for
Daniels's son so he goes to Professor
X's school too bad there's no x-men
crossover happening in the movies any
time soon but evany MA is the one that
goes for the mind gem possessed by
Doctor Strange so he sort of tried to
burrow into his mind to try and find
fantasies son but while this is all
going on the Illuminati decides they
need to assemble the Infinity Gauntlet
to prevent another Earth from another
multiverse from colliding with theirs
and destroying everything that they know
so they're blending a lot of modern
infinity elements with classic Infinity
Gauntlet but I think most of it is going
to try and be as true as possible to the
original jim Starlin story so if you
look at the Hulk here he's actually has
this bar
there in Edinburgh filming this scene
right here this might be a version of
this whole scene because at the
beginning of infinity war you sort of
jump around to a bunch of different
characters because at the beginning of
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline Santa's
actually snaps his fingers and erases
half of all life in the universe so
people like the Avengers all over the
place
within their respective cities just
notice that half of the people just
disappear
spider-man's like a wait a minute
where'd all these people go his spidey
sense goes off the charts
Captain America notices that Hawkeye
just disappears right in front of him
I guess that's bad news for Jeremy
Renner because he just left to go start
filming his infinity war scenes with
Scarlet Witch so would that not be
hilarious if they did a version of that
with Hawkeye in the movies people
complain so much after the first
Avengers film how Hawkeye got
mind-controlled he really didn't do much
of anything in that film so when they
get to the second one Joss Whedon's like
ok I'll write a really cool part for you
none of this makes sense but I'm going
back out there gives me my job ok I
can't do my job in baby stitch doesn't
matter what you did what you were to go
out there you fight and you fight to
kill staying here you're good I'll send
your brother to come find you but if you
step out that door you are an Avenger
but they've only been filming for a
little while so all this stuff you're
seeing here happens relatively early in
the film so in the comics he lasts a
little bit longer but then as you can
see here just kind of rips his guts
right out and disables him because he's
an Android he can sort of reconstitute
himself but the movie version is so
different because instead of the
sunstone that power said it's basically
like a solar gem the mind gem itself is
what gave him part of his consciousness
so he sort of the baby of the mind gem
in ultron so what would happen if the
mind gem part of him was ripped out
would that lead to a resurgence of the
Ultron parts of him I got a vision a
whirlpool instructional hope of life and
how did Santa is that what the gem the
mind stone one of the six Infinity
stones the greatest power in the
universe unparalleled in its destructive
capability you think I'm a child of
Ultron
you're not I'm not all from I'm not Java
silent I am but it seems like what's
going on here is that Corvus glaive
is catching vision by himself they
talked about the vignette it's
storytelling that's what they call it
they're going to be jumping around to
characters so like they're not all going
to be standing on screen together all at
the same time that might not happen till
the climax of the film after Thanos has
assembled the gauntlet and have to get
it off of his hand because if you wanted
to take the gems from the Avengers like
Doctor Strange who has the time gem
vision has the mind gem the best way to
do it would be to catch them when
they're on their owner they don't have
their friends around to help them and
none of the other Avengers were spotted
on set when they were filming these
scenes so Corvus glaive one of the most
badass members of the Black Order the
funny thing about this is the weapon he
wields is a glaive it gives him a
measure of immortality he can cleave
atoms in half he can pierce the hold he
can move with super speed super strength
super durability so effectively he can
take on any member of the Avengers and
we didn't really see a lot from vision
during Civil War I was a little
disappointed by the way they used him he
was really there to service more of
scarlet witch's storyline I know they
tried to tease that romance between the
two of them like there's some sort of
relationship but it was more about her
joining Captain America's Secret
Avengers by the end of the film so we
got to see him use the mind gem a little
bit but they said that that movie was
all about person versus person rather
than God versus God which is why Thor
and Hulk weren't around they wanted it
to feel like there were stakes and
vision is a God with the mind gem so he
didn't really get to be a God in that
film
so now we get to have a really dark God
come for this Avengers God so he gets to
fully open up it's like seeing the Hulk
Unchained on stack are like the craziest
version of the hope that you've ever
seen so I am so excited to see vision
get his ass handed to him in infinity
war he'll get a couple good shots in
but dannis needs to assemble the
gauntlet so let me know what do you
think is going to happen to vision after
they take the mind gem from him is he
going to be like a crumpled up pile of
robot parts that will slowly reassemble
itself or do you think it'll lead to a
resurgence of the Ultron parts of him
inhale go little sideways I think it's
more likely that he would wind up a pile
of crumpled robot parts on Tony Stark's
desk like they'll feel really sad
because their friend's dead they'll want
to avenge him but just remember he can
heal himself and what this might be is
just part of a journey for vision as a
character to learn who he is without the
mind gem like maybe he doesn't need the
mind gem the way Tony Stark doesn't need
an arc reactor inside his chest to be
Iron Man so if you weren't aware of that
Tony Stark took the arc reactor out at
the end of Iron Man 3 but he still has
an arc reactor he still has the armor so
the interpretation of that is that he
just doesn't have it in his chest
anymore they found a way to actually
remove the shrapnel
they were very unclear about that when
age of Ultron picked up but like this
Tony Stark had the reactor back in his
chest like what did he do so I guess we
have to assume that it's not in there
anymore he just has them in his suits so
what's going to happen next is is
WonderCon is happening this weekend
there might be some new footage dropping
from the studios but there's a new Star
Wars the last Jedi that I'm going to try
and post I'll try to get through
everything as fast as possible but leave
all your Marvel requests in the comments
below
congratulations to the latest marvel
giveaway winner Todd jumper please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for that next
video to post you can click here to
learn more about the black order and you
can click here for the spider-man
homecoming trailer thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys in the next video